Fitzpatrick: So this is our talk
about how to design--
Not so much how to design,
but how to think more in a--
about users when you're
writing software.
Collins-Sussman: Right.
Well, actually,
let's introduce ourselves first.
Fitzpatrick: Okay.
Collins-Sussman:
What's your name?
Fitzpatrick: My name
is Brian Fitzpatrick.
Most people
call me Fitz.
Collins-Sussman: My name
is Ben Collins-Sussman.
I'm just Ben.
And we are gonna
talk about--
It's a very
subjective talk.
It's based
on our experience.
We come from
the open source world.
We both worked on
subversion for many years,
and now we're at Google,
and we work on
an open source team,
and we actually work on
Google Code's project hosting
service.
That's what I do. You do some
great management stuff.
But what we do
essentially is--
everything we're talking about
is coming from our experience
of working with
communities of users.
Open source software,
closed source software,
what is--
what kind of relationship
do you have
with those users?
Fitzpatrick:
And this is completely
based on a series of anecdotes
that we're gonna tell
in addition to some
little bits of information,
but most importantly,
this is a subjective talk.
These are our opinions.
If you disagree with them--
and that's fine--
you can get your own talk,
and have your own opinion
somewhere else.
But seriously, we're--
this is--we're sort of
gonna tell this
through a series
of anecdotes
and things
that we've experienced.
And that's it.
Collins-Sussman:
Yeah, and there'll be
time for Q and A
when we're done, so--
First thing we want
to talk about
is we're all
programmers here, right?
Or most of us are,
so when you think about, well,
what does it mean to have
successful software, right?
There's a lot
of different metrics.
You can say, well, it's really
fast, or it has a lot of users,
makes a lot
of money, right?
Or something,
or maybe it's really clever.
But there are a lot
of things to think about
besides the technical side.
It's not just about
how great your code is.
It's actually
about...
Well, there's a whole
social aspect to it
that a lot
of programmers forget
because we're so busy
writing code all the time.
That's what we want
to talk about.
Fitzpatrick: Right, when
you're thinking about software,
engineers typically
think about the code,
and some twist of algorithm,
or writing software,
or a neat bit of Java
that they might write.
Collins-Sussman:
That's the meat.
Fitzpatrick:
Sort of the meat, right?
So people tend
to think about
the meat of
your application.
However, what you
don't really think about
is sort of, like, making
that look more presentable
and more appetizing
to our users, right?
Typically, in the past,
engineers have seen
what happens when people put
sizzle onto a product, right?
What you get is you get
a whole bunch of sizzle,
and you get a whole
lot of no steak.
Right? And so people
tend to be a little wary--
Engineers tend to be
a little wary of doing that.
Collins-Sussman:
Well, it's also usually--
It's a relationship with
the marketing department, right?
Ah, what are you doing
to our product?
What are you
promising about it?
What are you saying
about it, right?
And I guess we're here
to talk about how
that is not necessarily
a bad thing.
And trying to create
a better understanding
of what does it mean to add
sizzle to your product--
how do you make it
presentable to the public
without feeling like
you're compromising your ideals,
and, like, it's still
good software?
Fitzpatrick:
Right. Exactly.
So a lot of this stuff
is not gonna come
as a complete
surprise to you.
This is sort of an opportunity
to bring it together
as well as to remind you
of some of these things
that you might not
think of day to day
when you're sort of
down in the trenches
writing up an application.
Collins-Sussman: Pull it
from their subconscious.
Fitzpatrick:
Exactly.
So we're gonna focus
on three particular areas
in this talk.
Collins-Sussman:
Yeah, so the first part,
we're gonna talk
about marketing.
What does it mean?
How does it relate
to you as a programmer?
And when you think
about marketing, right--
Just say the word,
"marketing."
What is the first thought
that comes to your head, right?
You probably think
about this guy, right?
Ah, run away.
Want nothing to do
with him, right?
Fitzpatrick: This guy
is all sizzle and no steak.
Right?
This is what you tend
to think about, okay?
The real thing is
is that people are used to--
when they think
about marketing or stuff,
engineers are used to
being lied to.
Okay?
Engineers don't like
being lied to, okay?
Anybody know when
Duke Nukem 3-D was announced?
audience member:
[indistinct]
Fitzpatrick:
1997. Okay?
That was 11 years ago,
and it took 'em 11 years
to go out of business.
Collins-Sussman: 12.
Fitzpatrick: 12?
12 years.
Collins-Sussman: [laughs]
Fitzpatrick:
12 years ago,
but they never released
a piece of software.
And that's the type of distrust
that I think we as engineers
tend to harbor when we hear
about this type of stuff.
Collins-Sussman: I think we're
just inoculated as a culture
to any kind of advertising
or marketing, right?
We're skeptical
about everything we hear,
'cause we just believe that
marketing and advertising people
are always lying
all the time, right?
Programmers really don't
want anything to do with it.
Programmers are
very logical people,
they're obsessed
with finding the truth,
finding the true thing,
and only talking about,
you know, logical, true stuff.
I mean, we live
with compilers.
Those are the tools
we use every single day, right?
We like order,
we like predictability,
we like control.
We don't like listening
to people try to spin things
and then we're sort of
left to guessing
as to what's real
and what's not.
Fitzpatrick: Five years ago
I was the vice president
of public relations for
the Apache Software Foundation,
which is an organization
made up almost exclusively
of engineers.
And, you know,
most people thought,
oh, we shouldn't
have to do PR.
If we write
the best software,
people are just
gonna come use it.
And meanwhile,
other web servers
and other pieces of software
that competed with Apache
were eating their lunch
because when an analyst
would come up to a commercial
company and say--
Collins-Sussman:
"Where's your white paper?"
Fitzpatrick:
and "We want you
to answer this, this, this,
this, and this
about your software,"
and the company would, you know,
have four or five PR flacks
get down on their knees
and then worship the analyst
and tell them
how wonderful they are,
and they do all their work
for them and hand it to them.
And an analyst
shows up at Apache
for one project
in particular,
which will remain nameless,
and says, "Hey, we want
to know this, this, and this
"about your projects,
and blah, blah, blah,
"we're gonna write
a paper, et cetera,
and go do all this work,"
and their basic response was,
"Go screw yourself.
Join the mailing list
and find it yourself."
Collins-Sussman: "Go read,
you know. Go read our docs."
Fitzpatrick: Right.
Collins-Sussman:
"Not our problem."
Fitzpatrick: So the best
approach probably lies
somewhere in between
those two approaches.
The sort of sycophantic
begging, and then
the, like, "Go read
the mailing list."
Collins-Sussman:
Absolutely.
I mean, the other thing
that programmers like to do
is especially when
it comes to legal things,
they start trying
to interpret the law, right?
I mean, there's a lot
of issues that have to do
with marketing and PR,
and they always get entangled
with legal discussions, right,
licensing,
and what are we allowed
to say and or not say,
and programmers love to look
at laws and licenses
and try to process
them like code,
when in fact, if you are
a lawyer, or you know lawyers,
they will laugh at you if you
talk about that idea, right?
'Cause the legal system
is not perfectly rational.
It's not logical.
Fitzpatrick: What?
Collins-Sussman:
I know, it's crazy.
Fitzpatrick: Yeah, if you're
ever talking about something
legal with a license, you say,
"well, it should do something,"
stop yourself right there
because you're clearly
going down the wrong path.
Collins-Sussman:
Absolutely.
Fitzpatrick: But beyond this
sort of obsession with truth
is that we expect some sort
of a meritocracy, I guess.
That people put the most
effort into something
or the best
technical thing would win.
Collins-Sussman:
Right, but if that were true,
we'd all be using Betamax--
well, nobody uses
VHS either anymore--
but the classic
story, right?
Fitzpatrick:
But it had a good run.
Collins-Sussman: Betamax
was technically superior to VHS,
and yet VHS won, right?
So not everything--
the technically superior product
does not always
win, right?
That is not the only metric
you need to think about
when you're saying,
"well, how is my product
gonna be successful?"
You need some sizzle.
Fitzpatrick: Right.
Collins-Sussman:
To some degree you need it.
Whether you like it or not.
Fitzpatrick: So the point
that I try to make is that
truth is actually fungible.
Okay, there are
different shades of truth,
and this is a mean that
I've been trying to propagate
for years, which is that
perception--not procession--
but perception
is 9/10 of the law.
What it comes
down to is that--
Collins-Sussman:
First perception.
Fitzpatrick:
Exactly.
What people see is the reality,
whether or not it's true.
What people will believe.
And marketers have used that
to their advantage
for years and years
and years.
There's no reason
that we as engineers
shouldn't do that as well.
Collins-Sussman: Typically
in the first 2, 5 minutes
of using a piece of software,
you formed an opinion about it,
right?
It doesn't matter whether
you've--you know,
whether you read the docs
or you should have read
the docs, right,
or you get an opinion
about it very quickly.
There's either a good
or a bad barrier to entry,
and then you've
made up your--
and that's the truth
you now live with.
You have a certain feeling
about this software,
whether you were fair
in judging it or not.
Fitzpatrick:
Well, with Subversion
we were particularly
conservative
in calling Subversion 1.0
because when it comes
to a version control system,
if it loses your data,
you're probably
never gonna come back.
Okay, data--that's sort of
an important thing.
It's not really the best,
technically the best version
control system out there,
but it was generally
perceived
by people as being
a good thing.
Moving along,
one other thing
that you can sort of have
the sizzle in the steak
is that under-promise
and over-deliver.
You still have great things
to give to people,
you still have a great
piece of software,
but you don't have
to tell them everything
that you want
to give, maybe,
so you tell 'em
the first few things.
I come from New Orleans,
and in New Orleans
we talk about lagniappe,
okay, a little bit
of something extra.
Like you buy
a dozen doughnuts,
you get an extra doughnut
free.
You buy five pounds of meat and
you get a pound of liver free.
I don't know why that was
ever a good thing,
but apparently that's the way
it worked back in the day.
Collins-Sussman:
But you certainly
don't market that, right?
You don't write that
in the coupons, right?
It's just one
of those things you do.
In the same way
we're talking
about under-promise
and over-delivering,
Google, as a policy,
doesn't pre-announce products.
We don't send out endless
press releases saying,
"We're working
on this cool thing.
It'll be done
this quarter."
'Cause then essentially
we set ourselves up for failure.
It's a matter of, you know,
surprising people,
and saying,
"Isn't that wonderful?"
Fitzpatrick: You set your
expectations really high,
and then you wind up
with something
people aren't
looking forward to.
So that's sort of
the marketing angle,
and we want to talk a little bit
about customer service.
Now, sort of close your eyes
for a second and think--
what do you think about when
you hear "customer service"?
Collins-Sussman: Mmm...
Fitzpatrick:
In this day and age,
especially
in the United States,
people think
of customer service,
they think of a service-oriented
industry where someone
is doing something
for someone else,
and sort of a one-on-one
kind of thing.
Collins-Sussman: But it's
also sort of considered
the bottom
of the ladder, right?
Like, working the help desk
in a company.
Oh, my, no.
Customer service tech support.
Got to get out of there.
What a waste of time, right?
Fitzpatrick: So we have
a graph here
that we spent
minutes researching.
It's basically--
you start off, and you--
if you have
a successful piece of software,
you're going to get
more users over time.
That's what
everybody wants, I think.
I don't think there's
anyone in this room
who writes software that doesn't
want more people to use it.
The problem is is that
as you add users,
you don't stop
writing code.
You continue
adding to your--
the complexity
of your application.
Collins-Sussman:
More and more features,
more and more
feature creep, at least.
Maybe the users
are asking--
Maybe the power users
are asking for more features
so you're like, "Great, more
code, throw it in, throw it in.
Look how great this is."
Fitzpatrick: The problem
is is that as time goes on,
and your user base widens,
you attract less tech-savvy
users.
Okay?
And the combination of these
three different factors
results in an exponential
increase in despair.
Collins-Sussman:
Very carefully measured.
Fitzpatrick:
Exactly.
But the point is is that
this is something
that's really
important to realize,
is that this complexity
is very difficult
for users to sort of
grok and understand,
but you have to listen
to them.
This is part
of customer service.
You shouldn't just
assume that they're dumb.
We had a talk
yesterday at the ignite
that was just fantastic
where they were talking
about, you know,
give your users the real thing.
Don't give them
some dumbed-down,
toy version of that thing.
I think that's a great point.
Collins-Sussman:
Right.
I mean, they're not
dumb people necessarily--
Sure, a few of them
out there are dumb,
but there's not a safe
assumption to assume
that just because somebody's
asking a question or needs help
or doesn't understand something
about your software
that they're inherently
dumb in general,
or they're just not
techie people, right?
I mean,
if something is wrong
you actually need
to hear what's going on,
and the first step
is not be condescending.
It's to respect
and listen carefully
and really try to get
some empathy going
with what
they're experiencing.
I mean, we're so used to being
holed up with our compilers
and our code that we sort of
lose all perspective
of what the rest
of the world sees.
Fitzpatrick: Right, and people
just want to be heard.
So give them
an opportunity to be heard.
Even if they're not
writing code for you,
they can give you
valuable feedback.
Collins-Sussman:
You can let them
file bugs
in your issue tracker
and respond with them,
so then they
at least feel like
you are listening
to them in some degree.
Fitzpatrick: An example of this
is Google Moderator.
We've--you know, I mean...
Collins-Sussman: Oh, yeah.
Fitzpatrick: The White House
recently used that
to sort of get
questions from people.
And setting up a moderator
instance for, you know--
What do you guys want?
Let's get some feedback,
and let's get some people
to vote it off.
In the issue tracker,
users can star things,
and you can sort of
see themes.
And we notice this very clearly
in Google Code itself.
We have an issue tracker
for the product.
and we heard very clearly
different pain points
that people had,
and different features
that they really expected
the product to have.
Collins-Sussman: The trends
become really obvious
if you start
deliberately listening
and open--creating some kind of
open forum to get feedback.
It becomes very obvious
what's important and what's not.
rather than, you know,
just what you happen
to think is important
it's really
important to listen
and get that data
from the outside,
not just from the inside.
But there's a fear there.
People tend to be
afraid of doing that.
First of all, because they get
a lot of crazy ideas, okay?
And they feel like, oh, God,
if people start saying this
I'm gonna have to
wind up writing this,
which is not true.
Collins-Sussman: You don't
have to listen to every quack.
Fitzpatrick:
You don't have to listen
to every single idea
that comes in the long tail.
Just pay attention
to the ideas
that you're hearing
over and over again,
or the questions,
or the themes,
or the bugs,
that sort of thing.
Try to do fewer
things better.
And we sort of use
a metric of target in the 80%.
As opposed to the 100%.
Collins-Sussman:
Right, it's really--
I think it's really great
that if your product can do 80%,
it can solve 80% of everybody's
pain really really well,
you're great.
You see a lot of failure
happens when people
try to be absolutely
everything to everyone.
Every bell and whistle
in the world.
I mean, I guess one example
is Emacs, right? [laughs]
Fitzpatrick:
Exactly.
It's everything
to no one.
Well, a quick survey--
who in the room uses Emacs?
Raise your hand.
Who uses the I?
Okay, fight.
No, just kidding.
[laughter]
But seriously,
though, I mean,
I've been an Emacs user
for 12 years,
and it makes me crazy 'cause
it's just like the Swiss Army--
Collins-Sussman: Occasionally
you will see products out there
that try to be
everything to everyone.
There's some wacky--
We're not sure what this is.
I think it's...
Fitzpatrick: We actually
do know what this is,
so don't email us
afterwards.
People emailing us explaining
exactly what it is.
But, you know--
Collins-Sussman: Well, there's
more than one version of it,
so it must be
important, right?
Fitzpatrick: It has a lantern
on the back, too.
A big, like, tube lamp.
Collins-Sussman: But it's got
a competitor, right?
Fitzpatrick: Right, and there's
more of these things.
Collins-Sussman:
Don't be this. [laughing]
Fitzpatrick: So this
is an example of something
that's just utterly
terribly designed
'cause it's trying to be--
I think it's trying
to be too many things.
I understand it's an emergency
gadget, remember that.
Collins-Sussman: Okay.
But what's a good example?
Fitzpatrick:
Here's a great example, okay?
You can't boil
an egg in this,
you can't--you know, you can't
cook a whole turkey in it.
It's a toaster oven.
You can make toast,
you can toast a bagel,
you can do some small
pieces of fish, maybe...
Collins-Sussman:
Make pizza.
Fitzpatrick:
It does it really well.
And after we gave
this talk last year,
someone sent me
a picture of a toaster
with a radio
on the side of it.
Collins-Sussman:
Argh...
Fitzpatrick: I'm like,
you don't get the point;
that's not the point.
Collins-Sussman: So this is--
this does a lot of things.
Most things
for most people.
Incredibly useful
to a wide variety of people.
Doesn't do
absolutely everything,
but boy, you know,
it hits that sweet spot.
So the next thing
you need to think about,
I guess, is trust.
And what we mean
by that is it is--
Nice effect.
It's an irreplaceable
resource.
Trust is one of these
things that you--
It's a reputation
that you build up
with your users, and it's
one of those things that--
Makes me think of it
as, like, a bank account.
Every time you do something
well, or you listen to people,
or, you know, you help solve
their problem in some way,
you get a little
bit of money,
you put it
in that bank account of trust.
But it's very, very easy
to destroy that bank account.
You do one evil thing,
or one thing that's
a slap in the face of the users,
and all the trust is gone.
Fitzpatrick:
Well, people typically
do that
for short-term gains.
Your temptation to betray
user's trust, I think,
is for short-term gain, which
results in a long-term loss.
If you get users
to trust you,
and they like your product,
they'll stay with you
through thick and thin
for a very long time.
And the best
example of this
is how many people
in this room own a car?
How many people in this room
have a mechanic that they trust?
Collins-Sussman:
[laughs]
Fitzpatrick: Okay, see me
after this talk, please.
No, but seriously,
this is a great example of--
Collins-Sussman:
Why is that?
Fitzpatrick: I think mechanics,
for the most part,
aren't interested
in long-term customers.
I think it's harder
to do that.
Collins-Sussman:
It's an assembly line.
Right?
In these typical situations--
Oh, my car
needs maintenance.
I'll go take it
to some random dealer,
who I have no real personal
relationship with,
and they put it
through an assembly line.
Then they always
try to up-sell you
to do something that you
don't really need, right?
And we kind of
expect it at this point.
Fitzpatrick: My grandfather
owned--managed a Firestone store
for 35 years,
and after the first 20 years,
95% of his customers
were returning.
Return customers.
And that's because
he never tried to sell 'em--
They come in
for a flat tire,
he'd never try and sell 'em
a radiator flush.
"Oh, it looks like
you need
your flob-dangle zip-zopped
or something like that."
Collins-Sussman: Absolutely.
Fitzpatrick: People--
I don't think people--
Whether you know a lot
about a car or not,
I think it leaves you
with a sort of sick feeling
in your throat,
like, "I'm being played,"
you know, to some extent.
But we've got an example of that
in Subversion as well, right?
Collins-Sussman: We worked
on the Subversion Project
for many years,
and one of the things
we set out
at the beginning
is Subversion is basically
gonna be a set of APIs
with a small binary
that uses them.
'Cause we wanted people
to connect to them
and write alternate clients
and things.
But our APIs are very,
very structured.
They occur at many levels,
and they're full
of all sorts of promises
that "we will not change this,
we will not change this."
When new versions
of the product come out,
we very explicitly
mark it.
Old APIs as deprecated,
we do not get rid of them,
we make sure they work,
we keep them testing,
and that's just about--
you know, that's a certain
kind of relationship
with programmers.
They are another
kind of user--
Fitzpatrick:
But we reap the benefit--
We still get the benefits
of that today
'cause Tortoise SVN was--
which is an amazing piece
of software.
You know, those guys wrote
a really complex piece
of software
where that just made Subversion
much more popular in general.
Collins-Sussman:
Absolutely.
The thing you need
to think about
when you're listening
to a user, right.
Someone's giving you
a piece of feedback--
You often have to read
between the lines.
What we mean by that is
do what I want,
not what I say.
So, I mean, I had this problem--
like, for example,
trying to teach your parents,
who may not be tech savvy,
how to use a computer.
Maybe you're on the phone
with them or something.
They're saying one thing,
and usually you have
to sort of listen,
and it becomes a skill,
like, well, I think
what they really mean is X,
or they're
describing something
in a way that's
not familiar to you.
Doesn't mean they're dumb,
it just means they don't know
the same lingo as you, right?
Or maybe they don't know
how computers work--
Fitzpatrick: People have
a different mental model.
I mean, people have
a very different mental model
of computers--
how computers work.
Especially if they're
not engineers.
And I'm gonna digress
for a moment and tell a story
about a pencil sharpener
to give you an idea
of how different
peoples' mental models are.
A couple years ago,
my grandmother said, you know,
"Is your grandfather's computer
still any good?"
Now it's
a 1990 Macintosh SE.
You know, and it hasn't been
used in six or seven years.
I said, "Oh, you know,
I really don't think so.
"It's black and white,
"it doesn't have
an Internet connection,
"you know, it's probably
best to just, you know,
give it away
or recycle it or something."
She said, "Oh, okay,
'cause I only ever
turn it on anymore
when I need
to sharpen a pencil.
Collins-Sussman:
[laughs]
Fitzpatrick: And I stopped,
and I scratched my head,
and I lis--played that back
again in my head,
and I realized
I really have to know.
I probably don't
want to know,
but I have to know
what she's talking about.
So I start asking
some questions.
"Well, that's
interesting, grandma."
And it turns out that she has
an electric pencil sharpener
that's plugged
into a power strip,
into which this Macintosh
has been plugged into.
So once a week
she'd take her pencils,
she would go
into the office,
she would turn on
the power strip,
and the little Mac
would go, "beep,"
and it would start
firing up his hard drive
and reading
its operating system,
and she'd sharpen her pencils,
and she'd kill it.
Collins-Sussman: Cut the power.
Fitzpatrick: Mercilessly.
Before it even
booted up.
I-I--To let you know...
Collins-Sussman: Poor Mac.
Fitzpatrick: I rescued
this poor Mac from its fate,
and it's been
put out to pasture
with all the other Macs
and Commodore 64s and whatnot.
Collins-Sussman: That is a good
story about mental models.
Fitzpatrick:
Right.
I mean, this made
perfect sense to her, right?
But beyond that,
seriously--
Beyond just listening
to your users
and focusing on giving them
good service,
take the opportunity
to delight them, you know?
Collins-Sussman:
This is an art.
Fitzpatrick: Being whimsical
isn't actually bad.
I think it is an art.
And it's somewhat
of a cultural thing
across some pieces
of software.
Some pieces of software,
I think, do this really well.
Collins-Sussman: Well,
they'll put Easter eggs in,
or they'll do silly things,
but just something
so they're
not taking the host
quite so seriously.
They understand that there's
some empathy going on
between the software
and the company, and the user.
It's not just
this formal relationship.
Fitzpatrick:
Right, right.
Collins-Sussman: So I mean
Google's an example of that.
We do a lot
of silly things.
We've got doodles that,
you know, happen year-round,
and we get unbelievable
amounts of email
about particular doodles--
why we did do a certain doodle,
or didn't do a certain doodle.
Fitzpatrick: But no matter
what they do,
they get a big pile
of, "We love this!"
and a big pile
of, "We hate this!"
Collins-Sussman: I'll talk
to my relatives; they're like,
"Oh, did you see the doodle
that Google did last week?"
and I'm like,
"Uh, I guess so."
Fitzpatrick: We're talking about
inspiring passion in users.
I personally don't care
if you guys love this talk,
or hate everything we say
and disagree with it all,
as long as we spark
some reaction in folks
and make you think
a little bit about something.
You know,
if you're asleep,
then that probably means
we failed somewhere.
Collins-Sussman:
Google has a long history
of doing April Fool's jokes
as well.
Which--Every year
it's something different.
In 2008, every single link
on the YouTube front page
went to a Rick Roll.
Okay, great. It's funny.
Right? One day.
Fitzpatrick: But why
would you do that?
You know, most people
don't even, like--
It seems so impractical
and so whimsical.
But people
remember that,
and they're like, "Oh, God,
I remember; I was there."
Collins-Sussman: I think another
great case is you can use humor
to sort of encourage people
to do the right thing.
There was
a social networking site
that went up for a little while
where they really wanted
people to upload photos,
and a lot of people
won't do that
at first when they join
a social networking site.
So this site,
what they decided to do
was put in a default image of
Dick Cheney to every new user.
And, oh, my goodness, everybody
uploaded a new photo right away.
Fitzpatrick: Over 90% of their
users uploaded a new photo.
Collins-Sussman: Clearly
something humorous there, right?
But that's just another way
of delighting the users.
So the third thing we want to
talk about is focusing on users.
We talked about marketing
and customer service.
What does it mean
to actually focus on them
and have them affect
your everyday activities?
Fitzpatrick:
What do you think about
when you hear
"focusing on users"?
You usually think about
the orbiting brain lasers.
Collins-Sussman:
No, no, not released. Next.
Fitzpatrick: Oh, we don't
talk about prerelease. Sorry.
Collins-Sussman:
[laughs]
Usability.
Fitzpatrick: It sort of
falls under usability.
It falls under making
your software something
that people can comprehend
and do great things with.
If you just can't
try out your software,
you don't have
any users, right?
And like we said earlier,
the first impressions are really
key to this sort of thing.
Collins-Sussman:
And the barrier to entry.
Fitzpatrick:
The metaphor we like to use
is one of a storefront.
Okay, if you're walking
down the street,
you look in a store window,
and you see something--
"Oh, hey, there's
a doodad I want to buy."
You walk inside
and you inspect it.
Okay, that costs you
nothing but a few steps.
If you walk up to the door
and they say,
"Stop. We'd like you
to fill out this form.
All this information
about yourself."
You're gonna be like,
"Really? I just wanted to--
It's not that
important to me."
And they're gonna go away
before they even had a chance...
Collins-Sussman:
Read this documentation, right?
Read this
license agreement.
Fitzpatrick: Exactly.
Collins-Sussman: It's crazy.
Back to the Emacs and vi,
which we mentioned before,
when I first
was introduced to Unix,
years and years ago,
I remember saying,
"Which editor should I learn?
Emacs or vi?" and everyone in
the room kind of laughed at me
and said,
"Well, you figure it out.
Which one you want.
We're not gonna tell you."
So I started up vi,
and I really didn't know
what to do,
and I was typing things
and nothing was happening,
and I kind of got frustrated.
And I started up Emacs,
and I just started typing.
There were
characters appearing.
"Oh, this is just like
a word processor."
Fitzpatrick: How did you
figure out how to quit it?
Collins-Sussman:
Well, that was--I couldn't qu--
Fitzpatrick: I had
to unplug the computer
to quit Emacs
the first time I tried.
I'm like,
"You got to be kidding me."
Collins-Sussman:
I couldn't quit vi either,
but the point is,
at least, you know,
in the first ten seconds
I just had an initial
impression of, like,
"Oh, look, here's something
that's familiar to me.
At least it's behaving
somewhat like what I expect."
Now, maybe that's not
the perfect example,
but I think it's a nice anecdote
about first impressions.
Fitzpatrick:
Well, there's a lot of examples.
I mean, Perl and PHP
I don't--
They're not generally considered
really powerful things
for writing Web apps or general
apps, but they're really easy.
There's a really low barrier
to entry with these things.
Or Fink, for example.
If anybody uses Mac OS X,
there's this thing called Fink
that has all this
extra packages and stuff.
In Tiger, they had this
really nice disk image.
You just double-click it,
you install it, and it's done.
As soon as Leopard came out,
they didn't have this ready,
and so you had to download
things and build things
and go through
all this crazy stuff.
Collins-Sussman:
Everybody stopped using it.
Fitzpatrick:
Well, people eventually started.
Collins-Sussman:
Well, a lot of people did.
Fitzpatrick: But it was
a higher barrier,
and you're more
likely to say,
"Oh, heck with it,
I can live without this stuff."
Collins-Sussman: So one way
we like to think about usability
is we have this bell curve.
On one end we have
Donald Knuth,
on the other hand
we have Fitz's grandmother.
Fitzpatrick:
Who I love dearly, really.
Collins-Sussman:
We do love her.
I've never met her.
So the question is
where does your software fall
in terms of--we just want
to think about drawing a line.
Every user
to the right of the line
is able to use your software
with not much effort.
So we can sort of talk about
various pieces of software.
Fitzpatrick:
We're version control geeks,
so we think Subversion
actually falls pretty easy.
In the easy to use.
So there's a lot of people
that it's accessible to,
quite frankly.
Collins-Sussman:
Even people who've never
used version control before
find it not too hard
to get used to.
Fitzpatrick: Right,
and another example is Git.
Collins-Sussman:
[laughs]
Fitzpatrick: It's technically
a great piece of software,
but it's quite
hard to use.
Collins-Sussman: And you can
do anything with it, right,
but you have to be this tall
or this technically awesome
to even, like, get past
that first day or two.
I've heard people talk about
the first two weeks of using Git
as being sort of
mind-numbingly hard,
but I hear it's actually
getting better.
That line's moving
to the left now.
Fitzpatrick: So we're
big fans of Mercurial.
Collins-Sussman:
We are.
Fitzpatrick:
Which we think is actually--
sort of finds
a nice middle ground
for something
as powerful as that.
Collins-Sussman: Incidentally,
Mercurial is now available
on Google Code
Project Hosting,
if you haven't seen
our blog posts about it.
You can now use Mercurial
instead of Subversion
if you're setting up
an open source project.
So there's gonna be a talk
about that at 4:30 today.
So side note.
Fitzpatrick:
But the other thing to think--
We're talking about
barrier to entry.
We have a couple more
fun examples here.
This is sort of
the standard,
you know,
credit card application.
This is a massive
pile of stuff.
There's plenty of sites you've
been to that once you try out,
you fill out all this stuff.
Anyone in the room
ever use TripIt?
Okay, TripIt
is really cool.
Collins-Sussman: It's the best
user interface ever. Why?
Fitzpatrick:
For signing up
because you don't
have to do anything.
Collins-Sussman:
There is no user interface.
Fitzpatrick:
You just start--
You can use the user interface,
but you just start emailing
your trip to it,
all the information.
Rental car,
your flight, et cetera.
Collins-Sussman: You sign up
for a car and hotel and airplane
on the regular Web sites, you
get these receipt emails back.
"Thank you for registering
for your flight, thank you--"
And you forward those emails
to this email address.
That's it.
Fitzpatrick: And then
it sends you back this nice...
Collins-Sussman: Yeah, you go
back to the TripIt Web site,
and it's parsed
all your emails
and put them into
this beautiful itinerary.
And everything's organized.
It's just fantastic.
Fitzpatrick:
Super easy to use and try out.
Collins-Sussman:
Absolutely.
Fitzpatrick: And then people
wind up staying around.
Collins-Sussman: One of
the things I want to talk about
is users versus usage.
This is an interesting term.
We talk about this
a lot at Google.
We say, "I've got
50 million users."
And we're like, "Okay, well,
what does that mean?"
Are they actually
using it?
Some companies
will say, you know--
They'll say, "We had
50 million downloads,
so we must have
50 million users."
Well, wait a second,
you don't know anyone's
actually using your software.
So we talk about this
a lot at Google
as a metric of success
and usability.
We want to measure who is
actually using your software
for how long.
Fitzpatrick:
The example for that is--
Who knows what ar is?
The ar utility in Unix?
Collins-Sussman:
Anyone ever heard of ar?
It's in bin.
Fitzpatrick: It's bin ar.
It's the Unix archive utility.
It's installed
on millions and millions
and millions of computers,
but no one uses it.
Collins-Sussman:
Well, I mean, it's probably
on every Linux
and every Mac laptop out there.
But nobody--It has zero
usability but millions of users.
Fitzpatrick:
So who cares?
Collins-Sussman:
Zero usage.
Fitzpatrick: Right, right.
Collins-Sussman: Absolutely.
Fitzpatrick: So the next part of
focusing on users is sort of--
We're talking
about laziness, okay?
Now, I personally admit
I am incredibly lazy.
I would much rather write
an application than write code.
So the least amount of code
that I need to debug, maintain,
remember what the heck--
a document,
remember what it was about,
the better.
But when it comes to designing
your interface and stuff,
you really have
to spend more time
so that your users
can spend less time.
This is lazy.
Collins-Sussman: [laughs]
[audience oohs]
Your favorite
application.
Fitzpatrick:
Your favorite application.
This is lazy.
Collins-Sussman: Oh, yeah.
Fitzpatrick: Now I understand
this came back from the days
when, you know,
people didn't spend time
designing any sort of
a command line interface,
but, you know, I can't remember
a darn thing about tar
other than cfv and xfv,
I mean, that's about it.
Collins-Sussman:
Becomes a reflex.
Who knows what
the other stuff does?
Fitzpatrick:
You know, the--et cetera.
Mail a copy
to Martha Stewart,
whatever,
there's that command.
Collins-Sussman:
Oh, I hate this.
This is one of those things.
You know about the--
Fitzpatrick: This is
a huge pet peeve of mine.
Collins-Sussman: Where you go
to a Web site, and you're like--
Because, you know,
it's so, so hard
to parse out
spaces and dashes,
we wouldn't want
to stress our programmers out.
Let's make the users
do it instead. Great idea.
Fitzpatrick: Right,
or even then you get the one
where you have to enter
your phone number.
You type the first few letters
it automatically advances you
to the next one, and you've hit
Tab and go on to the next field.
Collins-Sussman:
Yeah. Great.
Fitzpatrick:
You make your users feel dumb,
and when people feel dumb they
hate you, and then they go away.
Collins-Sussman:
[sighs]
Fitzpatrick: But beyond
just the usability stuff...
Collins-Sussman:
Speed.
Fitzpatrick:
Speed is really important.
Collins-Sussman:
It's a huge impact on usability.
In fact it's one of those
things that actually--
it affects usability
in this sort of weird,
unconscious kind of way.
You may not realize
how fast or slow
something is consciously,
but it actually
affects your mood,
and it affects how you feel
about a piece of software.
You know, if you've used--
Especially on mobile phone
apps as an example,
certain applications will be
super quick and responsive,
others you'll click
a button
and you'll sort of
wonder what's going on.
You may not register
in your mind
that "I'm frustrated
with it,"
but it does actually
change your mood.
Fitzpatrick:
And change your likelihood
to use something
off the cuff.
So here's another graph that
we spent minutes researching.
Collins-Sussman:
Minutes.
Fitzpatrick: As time goes on,
and you get more users,
sometimes people notice
that the number of users
they have plateau.
And the marketing guys decide
at this point
we need more sizzle.
Collins-Sussman:
Clearly that's the problem.
Fitzpatrick:
That's the solution.
It's a way to solve this.
But what it also turns out
is if you look
a little more carefully,
because your users have grown,
your application's slower,
you've maybe got some
bad algorithms in there.
Collins-Sussman:
You're not scaling.
Fitzpatrick:
You're not scaling very well.
Your latency gets to
a point
where your existing users
use your application less,
and your new users either
come and go,
which is very little,
and of course
this all means
that despair increases
exponentially.
Collins-Sussman:
Very carefully measured.
Fitzpatrick:
Carefully measured.
So here's an example to give you
a little actual data here
with some math behind it,
which is that if you have
a million users,
which I think
would be great.
I don't think anybody here
wouldn't want a million users.
Each one of them does
20 requests a day to your app.
Of course we're talking about
some sort of network app here.
Each response
is 500 milliseconds too long.
Over the course
of an entire year,
you've wasted 116 years
of peoples' time.
Collins-Sussman:
Holy smokes.
Please stop
killing your users.
Fitzpatrick: So it just
is sort of a plea
to not kill your users.
So beyond latency, I'll talk
a little bit about complexity,
which we've
touched on earlier.
Collins-Sussman:
Yeah, complexity is not
necessarily an evil thing.
Some problems
really are complex.
But the thing you should be
striving for is to sort of--
There is an art to dealing
with complex problems
and yet taking that complexity
and still making it accessible,
but not just dumping it
in the user's face.
Fitzpatrick:
Right, and you don't have to
dump it in the user's face,
and you don't have
to dumb it down so that,
you know,
anybody can "use it,"
you make things very weak
and not very powerful.
Collins-Sussman:
We have a nice counterexample.
Has anyone ever
used Eudora email program?
Or maybe ten years ago?
Fitzpatrick:
I used to use Eudora, sure.
Okay, we've got
a couple of screenshots
of Eudora's preference panel.
Collins-Sussman:
Big.
Fitzpatrick: And I'm gonna count
through them really quickly.
Okay?
We have 1, 2, 3, 4,
5, 6, 7, 8, 9, 10,
11, 12, 13, 14,
15, 16, 17, 18--
Collins-Sussman:
What is that?
Fitzpatrick:
What is a "mood watch"?
Collins-Sussman: [laughs]
[audience laughs]
Fitzpatrick: Why do I need
a panel for a mood watch?
Okay, but there's more.
19, 20, 21, 22,
23, 24, 25, 26, 27.
27 separate panels
to configure a mail client.
Collins-Sussman: Hmm. Email is
a complex problem, right?
But you don't really
need to throw that
all in the user's
face like that.
It's absolutely insane.
What's a good example
of hiding complexity?
I think probably everybody has
one of these in their pocket.
Wow, is this a dated
picture now? It probably is.
But think about how hard it is
just designing an mp3 player.
Before the iPod came out,
there were a lot
of different models out there,
and they all had
millions of little buttons
and weird,
little fonts on there.
It was kind of hard to use,
and I think what Apple did--
the brilliant thing--
I mean, it's--
Clearly there's
a lot of electronics.
There's a lot
of complexity going on
just in terms
of hardware.
But the thing they did
was they took
this very difficult problem
of managing your music,
and they took it
off of this device,
and they put it
onto a real computer.
Fitzpatrick: With a keyboard.
With an actual keyboard.
Collins-Sussman: And they wrote
this beautiful piece of software
to organize it and manage it.
And then all that complexity
has shifted off to the computer,
where it's doable,
and then the device itself
becomes incredibly simple.
It just becomes
a very simple mirror
for playing back
all the complexity
that you've already
organized somewhere else.
Fitzpatrick: And this is still a
very complex piece of software.
It treats
your music as data.
You can rate things,
you can do genres,
you can do smart playlists,
all this stuff.
It's really quite
impressive.
Another example of something
that's incredibly complex
is Google Search.
If you really want
to strip this down,
it's basically a text box and
a couple of buttons and a logo.
Collins-Sussman:
You don't really need the logo.
Fitzpatrick: You don't even need
the "I'm Feeling Lucky" button.
Or the logo.
In fact, you can
just hit Return
and get rid
of the button entirely.
Collins-Sussman:
[laughs]
Fitzpatrick: That is a window
into a massive amount of data.
And it's not
just dumbed down.
You can still use
some very powerful
search operators
on there if you want.
Collins-Sussman:
If you're a power user
you can go learn
all the fancy syntax.
Fitzpatrick: Right, but it's
an illusion of simplicity.
Just typing whatever
into that box 90% of the time
gets you where
you want to go.
And this is sort of what it
looks like behind the scenes.
Collins-Sussman:
Piles of computers.
Fitzpatrick: But beyond that
we want to talk
about another way
of hiding this complexity.
Is abstractions.
Abstracting out
some of this complexity
is a way for you
to sort of hide, I guess,
some of the complexity
while still giving users
the opportunity
to do things.
The real problem with this
is that all abstractions
are leaking.
Especially if you use the Web,
you see this every day.
You hit a 404,
you're in a Web browser.
What happened?
Where am I?
Your plug-in isn't found.
Collins-Sussman:
Yeah, I mean, think about it.
Even the most non-technical
users, they see 404.
It's become part of
sort of everyday speak
even though people
don't know
where that comes from
or what that means.
That's an abstraction
leaking out to the user.
Which is not necessarily
a bad thing.
Fitzpatrick: No.
Collins-Sussman: I guess what
we're trying to advocate here
is that you don't need
to try and prevent all
abstractions from leaking,
instead you should go
and say, well, that's fine,
let's actually create a layer
that people can build on.
Like an API layer,
or some way so people could
get under the abstraction
and really do what they want to
if you're a powerful--
if you're a programmer.
Fitzpatrick: Right,
and so an example of that--
the Apache Web Server,
years ago,
decided that people
in some cases needed to do
more than just configure things
through a little text file.
So they had
a module interface
where you could hook
into the request response
in any one of a bajillion
different places.
But this gave people like
you guys, like the engineers,
the ability to really
do a lot with it.
And, you know,
Google knows this too.
Collins-Sussman:
Google Calendar, right?
I mean, everyone uses--
well, lots and lots
of non-technical users
using Google Calendar,
love it.
Given me all sorts
of testimonials of my friends
about how it's
changed their life.
And yet there's
a great API for it too.
You can mix it,
and match it, and embed it,
and all sorts of things.
Fitzpatrick:
And we could go on and on.
I mean, this whole conference
is about that.
This whole conference
is about the fact
that there's these APIs
to all our different products.
I mean, Lars this morning
in the keynote--
Did you guys go
to the keynote this morning?
You guys like Wave?
Does that look pretty cool?
Collins-Sussman: Yeah.
Fitzpatrick: Yeah?
Collins-Sussman:
[laughs]
Jury's out.
Fitzpatrick: They're all clapped
out from this morning, I think.
But they realize that it's being
able to hack into things
like maps and whatnot, and
access it through strong APIs
are what makes it
really great, I think.
So we have a couple
of stories to end up here?
Collins-Sussman:
Well, yeah. [laughs]
Um, I think this is your story,
but I mean actually we get--
I've had other people
tell me this as well.
Is that, all right,
Google's corporation's got
a lot of people,
but a lot of people
don't actually
realize that.
There's a lot of people
out there who really--
they just think Google's
part of their computer,
or they think it's part
of their Web browser,
and I've actually
met people who I'll say,
"Oh, I work for Google,"
and they're like, "Oh, I didn't
know anybody worked there."
Fitzpatrick:
Exactly, yeah.
My mother-in-law
introduced me
to some 82-year-old
friend of hers, and she said,
"This is my son-in-law,
he works for Google,"
and she looks at her and looks
at me like what am I doing here?
She said, "I didn't know anybody
worked at the Google."
Collins-Sussman: Well, we've had
the opposite, right?
Fitzpatrick:
Right, well--
Collins-Sussman: This is
my favorite so you tell this.
Fitzpatrick: One of
our other friends out here
told his aunt
that, you know,
everyone was going to Disneyland
a couple years ago.
Collins-Sussman:
All the Google employees.
Fitzpatrick:
All the Google employees were
taking a couple days and we were
gonna go to Disneyland.
And his aunt said,
"Well, you can't do that."
He's like, "What do you mean
I can't do that?"
She's like, "Well, who's gonna
do my searches for me?"
Collins-Sussman:
[laughs]
I sort of imagine, like,
you know, switchboard operators.
Fitzpatrick: Right.
Somebody with the Yellow Pages
looking things up.
But I mean, again this is
the way people perceive things,
and the point of that
is just to think about the fact
that the way that
you perceive your software
from the inside looking out
is very different
than people who aren't as
technical, who aren't engineers,
perceive your software.
Collins-Sussman:
So it's really--
it's not just
about the code.
I mean, yes, we all have an
inherent distrust of marketing,
and spin,
and interacting with users.
It's something that sort of
scares us as programmers.
But there's actually--
there is--
You are able to have
a healthy relationship
with these facts,
with these people on your team,
you just need to find
that nice balance
where you are promising
the right amount of thing,
they are promising
they're adding the appropriate
amount of sizzle to your steak,
and you end up with something
that's really, really usable.
Fitzpatrick: And you're
listening to your users as well.
And that's all we have
to say about that.
Thanks for coming.
[applause]
We do have a little time
for Q & A.
If you have any questions
come up to the mic
and ask them, please.
If you have any answers,
definitely come up to the mic
and give us them.
Collins-Sussman: Great.
Fitzpatrick: That's it? Anyone?
Oh, somebody's running up.
Collins-Sussman: Somebody.
audience member: Hi.
Are there any standards
that Google uses for processes
to kind of--to, I guess,
review products,
how they're being used?
Are there, like,
five steps
or something like that
that they go through?
Collins-Sussman:
I'm not sure I--
If there are any processes
to review how products
are being used?
Oh, you mean like
how do we evaluate usability?
audience member:
Yeah.
Fitzpatrick:
Like user experience?
Like research and stuff
like that? User testing?
We do tons of that.
Absolute tons of that.
I mean, everything you--
Sometimes if you're
doing a Google search,
you'll see results come up
differently, for example,
it looks a little different.
Collins-Sussman:
Once in a blue moon.
Fitzpatrick:
That means that, you know,
you just saw a test
that we tried out.
Try and see if people
behave differently
and how they behave.
So we definitely do
a lot of that.
Collins-Sussman:
We'll do experiments on people.
See how they change behavior.
That's an unwilling experiment
in that case.
You might be a subject
of experiment without realizing.
But we also do
deliberate experiments too,
where we actually will have
user discussion groups,
user focus groups,
or somebody will volunteer
to use a product
and we'll watch them
use the product
and study what they're doing,
and it's classic
user experience stuff.
Fitzpatrick: Thank you.
Next question.
audience member:
Uh, are people who--
or kids who are grown up
with phones and computers
from very young ages--
How is this gonna change
the way users see
and use software,
and how is this gonna
change
over the next 20
or 30 years
as everyone starts to know how
to use a computer from--
they're two years old
or whatever?
Fitzpatrick:
Well, I think the bell curve--
The competency level is just
gonna continue shifting
as more people
are used to having
these sort of technical devices
around,
and that sort of thing.
Collins-Sussman:
I guess I don't feel like
it's a big paradigm shift.
I mean, when I was a kid
there were hardly
any computers at all.
But yet, you know,
everyone in my generation,
my parents' generation, grew up
with other forms of technology
that they did not
understand.
How many people understand
their television sets,
or the electricity or the
heating system in their house?
I mean, none of us can go
be dropped in a field
and survive anymore.
We've all lost
that ability to some degree.
We're all dependent
on technology to some degree.
So to me, computers
and cell phones just feel like
just yet another
piece of magic in our lives,
just like everything else that
we use to sustain ourselves.
Just one more thing.
Fitzpatrick: I agree
and I disagree a little bit.
I mean,
I agree that people
don't understand
the internals of something,
but I think they're
gonna be much more capable
of dealing with more complex
technological things.
I think we see that as--
And I think that's more
of what your question was,
if I understood.
Collins-Sussman:
And more OCD.
Fitzpatrick:
Yeah, and a little more OCD.
And you're gonna see people
talking to each other less
and just texting each other
more, something to that effect.
The social implications
are interesting, I think.
It brings people together,
to some extent,
and maybe brings them apart,
we don't know.
Yes.
audience member: Yes, I wonder
how both of you think
about designing software for
the way users currently think
versus taking them into
a new model of doing things.
And one example
that jumps to mind was Gmail.
How there was
no Delete button at first,
and we're trying to push them
towards a totally new model
and then eventually caving
and adding the Delete button.
Fitzpatrick: I personally agree
with the Delete button.
Even though I rarely use it,
it's nice to know--
It's like
an emergency exit, you know.
I don't want
to have to use it,
but it's nice
to know it's there.
Collins-Sussman: I think there's
a tightrope you need to walk.
I mean, if you have
a new, radical way
of working with software,
I don't think it will
get a lot of uptake
if it's completely alien.
I think you need
to find some balance
between somewhat familiar,
and then users are willing
to tolerate a little bit
of the unfamiliar
if they see an obvious gain
in productivity or something.
And I think Gmail
is an example of that.
It's like, okay,
it's a familiar.
I've used email before.
But a lot of friends of mine
who started using Gmail
weren't used to seeing
conversations grouped together,
and that was
a little bit of a shock,
but it was not so much
that they ran away screaming.
And now, you know,
months later,
I can't remember
living without it.
Fitzpatrick: Right.
But there's huge advantages.
I mean, you still have to offer
a net gain to your users
if you're gonna have
something new like that.
Gmail's first offer
was a gigabyte of storage space,
which was two orders
of magnitude
more than anybody
got at the time.
And people really thought
it was an April Fool's joke
five years ago
when they announced that.
'Cause it was--I did.
Collins-Sussman:
Announced on April 1st.
Fitzpatrick: I was like,
come on. This is crazy.
Who could do that?
audience member: So I work
at GrayShark.com, right,
and we have
a very healthy rivalry
between everybody
in engineering that thinks
that we should test
8,000 shades of gray,
and our designers that say,
"Hey, this is the right one."
Everybody in engineering
points to the fact
that Google
tests things a lot.
Everybody in design points to
the fact
that one of the famous
Google UI designers quit,
and her famous thing was,
"It took months to do anything
'cause we had to test
8,000 shades of gray."
So the question is, you know,
from your experiences,
where do you
draw the line?
You know, where do you really
find kind of the best compromise
between testing
a bajillion shades of gray
and then just actually
implementing one
that you know will work?
Without, like--
so when you're going forward
and you're building features,
There's, you know,
the continuum
of testing every version
of every possible thing,
or there's just doing it
the way you envision it
and the way
that you think will work.
How do you balance that?
Do you have
any suggestions there?
Collins-Sussman:
It's an interesting tension.
Fitzpatrick: Yeah, I think it is
an interesting tension,
and I probably have
a little different view
than a lot of people
on that.
So anybody here familiar
with EveryBlock.com
or ChicagoCrime.org?
EveryBlock.com
is an amazing site,
especially if you live
in one of the cities it covers.
But Adrian Holovaty, who
started it, is a friend of mine,
and I was talking
to him, like,
"Why does, like, the Jango
Web site look so beautiful?
Why does ChicagoCrime
look so beautiful?"
I'm like,
"You're not a designer.
"I know you're
not a designer.
You're a journalist
and an engineer."
And he said,
"It's because I have a UX
designer who I really trust,
and I can leave him to make
all the decisions for that."
User experience
and user design, I think,
Is actually
incredibly sophisticated,
but it's a thing
that most engineers--
myself too,
at some point--
think that they can
just understand.
Same for PR.
I think most engineers are like,
"Oh, this is a soft skill,
I could figure this out,"
when you really can't.
And you don't have as much
of a respect for, I think,
other peoples'
abilities in that.
So I personally believe
that most of the time
if you can find
someone who you trust,
and let them sort of
make that decision...
If there's not a lot of trust
between those two,
I would say you might
have some issues,
especially if you don't respect
what they're doing or saying.
Collins-Sussman: I think that
the tension you're pointing out
is between art
and science.
There's an art to it,
and there's a science to it.
Some people have good taste,
some people have terrible taste.
Fitzpatrick: That's subjective.
We always have good taste.
Collins-Sussman:
Always. Right.
Everyone else
always has bad taste.
But I guess my feeling about it
is you need to find people
with good taste to get you,
you know, 80% of the way there.
And maybe they'll make sort of
the artful decisions
that are more emotional,
less rational,
to sort of decide maybe
the overall look and feel,
or what features
are exposed or whatnot,
and then that last 20%
can sort of go into the realm
of scientific testing.
Like, what color
should this be?
Exactly how wide
should this part be?
And maybe there really are
measurable usability metrics
that come from
that scientific bit.
So there is a tension,
but I think they can cooperate.
If you--
if you do it right.
It's not all
one or the other.
Fitzpatrick:
And I still think
that there's opportunity
for testing.
In the engineering side,
you can make it easy
to do experiments
or that sort of thing,
especially if you're
dealing with network apps
and not something
you have to, you know,
buy a CD and download it.
Those days are thankfully
going away, I think.
But again,
there is a balance there,
but I think
it really requires
some sort of trust
and respect
of the folks
on the other side of the fence.
Just like it requires trust
and respect for your users.
That they're staying--
What they want--What a majority
of them say they want
is something that's good
to add to your product.
Collins-Sussman:
UI is a really hard field.
Fitzpatrick:
It really is.
And engineers beat the heck
out of UI people.
Collins-Sussman: Anyone who may
not be a programmer
must not be
very skilled.
There's sort of this weird
bias in the industry.
Fitzpatrick: What are
the different things
that engineers
think they can do?
UI design, PR, legal stuff.
All these different things.
Just read things they had
compiled into a head, right?
Rarely is it the case.
Next question.
audience member:
So as a person that actually
does a little bit
of everything--
engineering,
UI design, everything--
I can say that actually UI
design is pretty difficult.
Something that
I'm still having
a hard time getting
a good grasp of it.
One of the challenges
that we're having is that
I mean, what's a preferred
method of educating your users?
So you do have
a piece of technology
that you can do
fantastic stuff with it,
but you need to get users
to use it the right way.
There needs to be
a little bit of education.
I know it goes
counterintuitive--
So you have to
make it simple enough
that everyone can just
get it right off the bat.
What if there are--
Like, for some of
the mail application
you guys showed
from Eudora,
that was an overkill,
but what if there
is some essential steps
that they really
have to take?
In your experience, what's the
best recommendation to do that?
Is it videos,
images, step--making--
splicing it up so people
go into chunks?
Fitzpatrick:
I'd probably start
with user testing,
quite frankly.
'Cause I think once you--
If you get something and you
put someone in front of it
who's not a super
tech-savvy person,
who's unfamiliar
with it,
and look at what
they do first.
Look at what confuses them,
look at where they get lost.
I think that's a very
telling kind of thing.
Beyond that,
certainly documentation,
you know, fun videos.
I mean, remember years ago
Rails did that video
of how easy it was
to build an app.
And that was a huge win
for those guys.
You know, 'cause it was
a couple minutes long,
and you could see
how easy it was
to build their
sort of demo app.
Collins-Sussman: The things that
I've seen actually not work well
is when a company puts
all their eggs into either--
People learn sort of
bottom up or top down.
And some people want the
overview, they want the video,
they want to read
the manual.
And some people
just want to jump in
and play with it
and figure it out as they go.
And there are
different techniques
for teaching both ways,
and one of the things
I see companies don't do
is they choose
just one technique.
Like, maybe they'll have
an online help system
that's just
for bottom-up users,
but there won't be
an overview anywhere.
Or maybe they'll do a video
that has a general overview
of how the system works
and how cool it is,
but then there won't be
any bottom-up learning.
No, you know, help system
that's sort of contact sensitive
or anything like that.
So I think you need to think
about both kinds of users.
That's my pet peeve.
audience member:
And also, can you guys--
Are you guys familiar
with the process that Google--
that the iPhone team
had to go through
in order to make
the Google mobile app?
Fitzpatrick: Um, no I'm not.
Collins-Sussman: No idea.
Fitzpatrick: Got about it online
if you know, maybe.
audience member:
Thank you.
Fitzpatrick: They go to Steve
and yells at him or something?
Collins-Sussman:
Well, should we call?
Fitzpatrick:
I think we're gonna--
We'll be up here
for a few minutes
and then we'll step
outside,
but if you have anything else
you want to chat with us about,
please stop by.
Thanks again for coming.
Collins-Sussman: Thank you.
[applause]